Raphael is with us in Pennsylvania hi
Rafael how are you Oh Dave how are you
today
better than I deserve what's up I have a
question I'm on baby step two right now
we've kind of done the ramsey ish in the
past and after everything that's been
going on we've really been trying to
buckle on to our finances because there
was no worse feeling than you know the
data things were shutting down and i'm
watching the market crash and i'm just
in total panic about all the debt that i
had so me being I'm a disabled veteran
you know my might my money comes from
the government and I have a bunch of
debt that I'm trying to get rid of and I
feel like I can achieve it with the
Ramsey program but more importantly if I
can get rid of I have these I have a
truck a van and a camper letting out my
driveway and they've all been recently
purchased with all within the last two
years or so and I'm wondering is there a
way that I can sell my vehicles and get
the title even though I'm upside down on
it like how can I achieve that I mean
that's my main question for them to
cover the difference okay so let's go in
for instance about the truck okay the
truck the truck is worth what probably
t25 piyo 34 on it okay so you're nine in
the hole in this example right and who
did you borrow the money from Capital
One okay on a local branch or just
national and it set up there's a dealer
they were set up through the dealer okay
all right you're probably going to have
trouble getting any help from them
sometimes the bar the lender you
borrowed it from will let you sign a
note for the nine thousand dollar
difference give you the title for the
other twenty five thousand that you get
from the buyer and you hand the title to
the buyer and that's how a typical deal
works if Capital One won't do that then
you've got to cover that nine thousand
with borrowed money or saved money okay
but I'd rather you been nine thousand
dollars in debt than thirty four
thousand dollars in debt okay so you
think you think taken out
personal loans you cover the difference
yep really oh yeah really
wouldn't you rather be $9,000 in death
and 34 I would I just same thing on the
camper I just didn't expect that answer
from you well I mean you're not
borrowing money you're already 34 in
debt we're just borrowing
I mean we're borrowing we're moving some
9,000 of it into a different kind of
debt and reducing it by 25 in our
example so that's what that that's an
answer I would it's very consistent with
what we teach same thing with the camper
same other thing of the other car what's
the other car worth probably nine and I
owe 14 on it okay what about the camper
the camper I just bought last year's
it's why I bought it for twenty thousand
I don't know how they'd appreciate it I
bought a twenty twenty year I don't know
what that fast
I'm really the only year I can only get
rid of it and be able to get the most
out of it yeah you need to get rid of it
fast you may want to keep the other car
what's your household income sixty four
thousand this is me yeah this is what
she doesn't work she she was an excuse
me the nurse for 14 years and does she
work around that
and now she doesn't she's in school
right now okay that's cool I'm just
trying to figure out what your income is
because you said just me and I didn't
know she you kidding I'm not allowing
you keep your finances separate either
yeah so here's the deal dude you have
stupid piled up in your driveway a lot
of it I mean look at these numbers
thirty-four thousand and twenty thousand
is fifty four thousand and you make
sixty four thousand unless you're gonna
live in this camper this was really dumb
hmm it's got to go I'll probably keeping
the her car but your truck and your
camper are insanity and so you said you
were doing ish no you weren't you
weren't even close to age you were all
the way on the other side of the field
hmm and we're gonna reel you over here
because you don't like the feeling and
I'm with you brother I'll help you but
part of me helping you is we have to go
okay I'm not doing that crap anymore
because it's destroyed my life you've
been doing this for 30 years is there
anything that gets people to move from A
to B
without a everything falling apart
around them yeah sometimes I just get
disgusted you don't have to have a heart
attack to decide to lose weight you can
just get tired of your pants not fall
right I want everybody to hear that one
call and just go yeah you're right
that's really ridiculous
we have $100,000 or $70,000 worth of
toys in the driveway
and I only make 65 here's what's
interesting okay you just stop think
about this and do this as an exercise
folks because what I don't noticed this
the other day we were going to some
friend's house and we drove into this
neighborhood and these are nice houses
but their middle-class houses and the
cars in the driveway
down through this neighborhood were
worth almost as much as the houses as
you know I'm adding up there okay there
sits a master craft boat that's 110,000
sits a ring or over and there sits a
Lexus and you add those three things
together compared to their house and
then the weird thing is you go into a
home an area where the homes were maybe
worth twice that and you see a used
Lexus sitting there or you see a Ford
Explorer there a Camry yeah because they
don't care what you think about what
they drive you know and it's like this
is what we talk about you do rich
people's stuff so watch what rich people
do they drive used cars until they're
all uber wealthy you know if you got ten
million dollars or more and you want to
buy something super fancy that's fine
but drive like no one else so later you
can drive like no one else and make sure
you're you know the ratio of the car
that's in your driveway to your income
the ratio of the cars that are in your
driveway to your home doesn't make you
look like a poor person mm-hmm with
payments it makes when I drove through
that neighborhood that first neighbor
I'm talking about
I saw payments I drove through the other
favorite neighborhood there were I
didn't see payments and I want I want
folks to know that when you cannot cover
up what you see in the mirror with a
Range Rover that you drive about 45
minutes a day right yeah 30 minutes this
way and 15 minutes on the way back or
whatever the if you have friends or a
date or people that are impressed by
that are close to you what you drive you
have the wrong date the wrong friends
and the wrong people
hey that's how I knew my wife loved me
for me because my
yourself easy hatchback that both of us
can barely fit on was questioning that